le président de la république va donc
passer la nuit à l'hôpital militaire du
val-de-grâce sous surveillance
cardiologique nicolas sarkozy a fait un
malaise en fin de matinée alors qu'il
faisait son jogging dans le parc de la
résidence de la lanterne à versailles
l'elysée a communiqué très vite et tout
au long de la journée
surtout pour rassurer le chef de l'état
a même reçu ses principaux
collaborateurs pour selon son entourage
se tenir au courant de l'actualité
frédéric cros tarnos compte christophe
quincke en tout début d'après-midi 14h59
précisément l'elysée publie ce
communiqué alors qu'il faisait du sport
le président a eu un malaise et a été
immédiatement pris en charge par son
médecin
une information qui est relayée deux
minutes plus tard par l' agence
france-presse
c'est ici dans ce parc public qui
entoure la résidence présidentielle de
la lanterne à versailles que nicolas
sarkozy faisait son jogging vers 12h15
un témoin aperçoit le président entouré
comme à son habitude de ses gardes du
corps
j'avais l'impression qu'il faisait
vraiment un effort pour courir il très
mais presque les pieds il il avait l'air
assez fatigué je les croisais une
deuxième fois
une dizaine de minutes plus tard vers
12h25
et là nicolas sarkozy ne courait plus il
marchait lentement quelques minutes plus
tard d'autres témoins constate une
certaine agitation ce qu'on a vu un
hélicoptère de la sécurité civile et
puis une ambulance du samu autour d'eux
de la lanterne en fait vers 13h à peu
près victime d'un malaise vagal
le président est ensuite transporté par
hélicoptère de versailles à l'hôpital du
val de grâce à paris pour y subir des
examens médicaux
cet hôpital militaire et depuis le
milieu d'après midi sous la haute
surveillance des agents de sécurité de
l'elysée
la presse internationale est déjà sur
place quelques badauds se sont
rassemblés devant l'elysée ce soir où
l'on ne constate aucun signe d'agitation